[Music]
it is a
true treat to have none other than
really uh a tremendously influential
person in my life in my career i had the
honor
of knowing him when i was at caltech uh
for a glorious few years back in to the
early 2000s i can't believe john it was
been
20 years since we first met uh and it's
none other than john prescott who is
joining us today
from from pasadena california john how
are you doing today
i'm doing great it's really good to see
you brian it's great to see you
i can't tell you how much it means that
you're on the show you're you know
basically my most requested guest
uh that uh that i've that i get on a
frequent basis
although we're branching into
alternative topics now we just had on
our first show about bitcoin
and we will talk about quantum
cryptography and we will talk about
cryptocurrency
and all sorts of things so just for
those out there what are the promises
and
pitfalls perhaps of things that john has
made foundational contributions to
and but i really wanted to start off by
talking about
what the uh what the nature of your
research is and how
people can learn more about your
research we figured that we would
kind of um discuss the implications and
the applications of
of quantum computing to fundamental
physics
i i my audience is very astute they know
a lot about quantum mechanics and about
uh
issues related to quantum mechanics but
can you give a quick update on
what uh or quick summary how do you
think about
a quantum computer what is the essence
of a quantum computer
to john prescott
well it's a device which makes use of
quantum mechanics
to achieve big speedups
compared to classical computers for
solving
certain classes of problems and the
types of problems for which a quantum
computer
is particularly well suited
is of characterizing the behavior of
quantum systems
so i you know from my point of view as a
physicist
and with a background in particle
physics the way i think about this whole
field of quantum information is that we
are
in the early stages of exploring a new
frontier of the physical sciences you
know
very well brian that if i want to
go more deeply into the early history of
the universe
as you do in your work then we build
more powerful instruments
or if we want to explore the structure
of matter on shorter and shorter
distance scales
we build more powerful
particle accelerators and if we want to
explore
matter as it becomes more and more
highly complex
that's what we can do with the quantum
computer because
when we have many particles interacting
quantum mechanically states become very
entangled that's the word we use for the
characteristic correlations among parts
of the quantum system
and with ordinary computers we just
can't simulate the behavior
of highly entangled matter efficiently
and that opens opportunities for
discovery so
sometimes i speak of the entanglement
frontier or complexity frontier
because we would like to go more and
more deeply into
the behavior of these very highly
entangled states
and a quantum computer is the instrument
if you like
which will allow us to do that and when
you think about the you know fundamental
paradigm of biology
you know might be evolution progressing
by uh you know encoding of information
via dna
uh what and and in cosmology it's
characterized
the universe characterized in large
scales by isotropy homogeneity
is there a fundamental theorem or
catechism
of quantum computing or is it still as
cho in lai said of the french revolution
in the 1970s
too soon to tell
well there's a sort of a
a fundamental principle of computational
science
which sometimes people call the church
turing thesis
which is that we should be able with
a computer that's universal that can do
any computation
to efficiently simulate anything
that happens in nature and
that's not something that we can prove
it's a statement about physics really
but it was a widely accepted principle
until the advent of quantum computing
because we don't think with the standard
model
of computation the turing machine model
that we can efficiently simulate
very highly entangled matter but with a
quantum computer we think that is
possible that with
a quantum computer as far as we know we
should be able to efficiently simulate
any process that occurs in nature and so
we need to update
that church touring thesis replace it by
a quantum church touring thesis and so i
would say our operating principle
when we think about using quantum
computers to explore nature
is that if it happens in nature we have
the hubris
to believe that we can simulate it
with computers that we understand in
principle
how to build but if we want to do those
simulations efficiently they'll have to
be quantum computers
so i've said actually getting a couple
of comments in the chat that your audio
is still
a little on the low side john is there a
way you can either move
closer or um is is that uh that's an
external microphone is there a way do
you have an
internal microphone if you just
disconnected the uh
let's see if that would work
um well that's already better actually i
don't know what you did
okay well i don't think i did anything
all right i turned my head
let's see the microphone is uh yeah the
closer you can get to the microphone the
better people are all right
how about i got it a little closer to my
face now
oh that's much better yeah people are
asking if
if this is quantum audio they don't want
it so
the future better be not uh this this
level of audio quality apologies for
that everybody but we're here with john
fresco on the into the boy they
you guys missed some really great stuff
yeah i know we'll never repeat it
no we uh we got all of it and it's just
the audio is just a little inconsistent
uh there's a little bit of background
but anyway we're here with john prescott
into the impossible podcast please do
subscribe to the channel
exercise your finger john will tell you
that carpal tunnel syndrome is rampant
the best exercises to press every couple
of seconds the like button the thumbs up
button
and uh subscribe but also subscribe to
my newsletter at briankeating.com i'll
send you some resources from
this conversation with john we're going
to talk about really some exciting
developments in fundamental physics so
we talked a little bit about the
fundamentals of quantum computing
maybe what the fundamental theorem of uh
quantum calculus is
in uh in in comparison to cosmology and
and
uh and other branches of science i've
heard it said
and this is all with or due respect
intended that you know the only thing
that quantum computers are good for is
cryptography and
simulating quantum computers what would
you say after you punch someone in the
face who would say that to you
what would you say to such a person well
i would say we have a very limited
understanding of what
quantum computers will be able to do we
don't
expect quantum computers to be able to
efficiently
solve all the problems we might care
about far from it
in particular the problems that the
computer scientists call
np hard or np complete
the hardest problems among those
for which we can verify the solution
once we find it
quantum computers can speed up finding
solutions to such
problems just by speeding up the
exhaustive search
for a solution but they don't speed that
up
so dramatically that it will really you
know change the world
uh so it is special problems with the
right structure
for which quantum computers have a very
large advantage
for which the uh
speed up that you can achieve is
essentially exponential you know you can
have
a problem whose solution takes a time
which is
exponential in the size of the problem
on a classical computer and in some
cases uh solve that
far more efficiently in a time that just
scales like a power of the size of the
problem
so that's where quantum advantage is
really
spectacular and you mentioned the two
examples which are uh most prominently
known
the application to cryptology and the
application to quantum physics
now it's likely there will be many
others
but i think partly because we have
limited imagination and limited
understanding of the power of quantum
computing
we haven't as theorists done a very good
job so far
in identifying a much broader class of
application areas and in a way maybe
that's not so surprising
um in the case of
classical computation there are many
examples
of algorithms which um
theorists weren't able to promise would
be powerful
but by experimentation it was found that
they
work quite well when we have quantum
computers to experiment with
which are of sufficient scale that they
can start to solve hard problems we'll
have the opportunity
to try out heuristic ideas for
quantum speedups and see how well they
work and
the hope which we can't guarantee is
that that well
will open a lot of other um potential
applications
which can be very impactful on society
but for me as a physicist even if
um what quantum computers turn out to be
best suited for
is simulating quantum physics
that's already a very powerful and
interesting
application not just for advancing
science
but i think for practical applications
at least in the long run we're not sure
how far off in the future
i'm talking about in discovering new
materials
and new types of chemical catalysts and
so on
so those applications are part of what
propels the interest and
the field um but realistically
that's going to require a much more
powerful quantum computer than we
currently have and it might still be
decades away
before we'll see that kind of impact as
for
uh cryptology of course um you know
that what generated great excitement
already over 25 years ago
was in 1994 when a peter shore
discovered that with quantum computer we
can speed up
greatly solutions to some number
theoretic
problems like finding the prime factors
of a large
composite integer and because the public
key
crypto schemes which we now all use in
our daily lives to
protect our privacy when we communicate
over the internet
since those are founded on the
assumption that certain computational
problems are too hard to solve in
practice
that's going to be upended when quantum
computers
are widely available
i think you know so so the world is
going to have to adjust
to that and we can talk about that more
if you like um i think as
the world adjusts that application will
sort of
uh recede in importance it's sort of a
historical accident
i expect that quantum computers came
along
at a time when uh these public key
schemes were
in widespread use and there are
alternatives that we'll
use in the future to replace those
schemes will still be able to protect
our privacy
in ways that are not vulnerable to
attack by quantum computers
and then the application which will
really impact the world that we
are confident about and understand
reasonably well is the application
to characterizing and simulating quantum
systems
and when we look at quantum systems i
find most remarkable although
you know i'm a complete uh neophyte
in this field and i just look at it with
admiration
and respect for both the enthusiasm of
the people working
in this field which is quite different
than your early work as a grad student
with stephen weinberg and your
contributions you made
to um you know topological defects to
magnetic monopoles and cosmology and
we'll get to cosmology i hope
and black holes in your relationship
with stephen hawking and the many bets
you guys engage with but i do want to
point out that from this novice's
perspective one of the most remarkable
things about quantum computing is that
it can be done at all
because either we use the properties of
single quantum systems
you know individual electrons their
spins or some or collectives and you
know persistent currents and phases and
quantum
and qubits uh we use uh jose's
injunctions superconducting quantum
interference devices squid amplifiers
and our
microwave background research what's the
most remarkable thing to you is it that
we can manipulate
both megascopic macroscopic and the
microscopic or is there something else
that really
betwixes you and uh and really uh stokes
your curiosity about this particular
field of quantum mechanics
well it was also important that when the
idea of quantum computing
came along and when the recognition
grew that quantum computers would be
able
in principle theoretically to solve hard
problems we couldn't otherwise solve
the the developments in experimental
physics
were poised to um
you know take us into the era where real
quantum hardware could be constructed
you know when uh decades ago when one
talked about doing
experiments with quantum systems they
were
almost always ensemble experiments
where say if you were trying to describe
the behavior of an atom or
doing a nuclear magnetic resonance or
something like that you were looking at
a
signal from many atoms or
many electron spins and so on but
uh you know by the 1990s we had the
tools
to manipulate quite uh
accurately to control single quantum
systems like single atoms
and that was technology was developed in
part because it was motivated by the
desire
to make more accurate atomic clocks
like trapped ion technology for example
but it's also very well suited for doing
quantum computing
where one needs to be able to control
individual qubits or even more
importantly
the interactions between pairs of qubits
qubits
meaning the quantum analog of bits
quantum bits which we call qubits two
atoms for example
it's possible uh with um
lasers and using the
vibrational modes for example of ions in
a trap
to control quite precisely the
interaction
between two trapped ions and therefore
to do an elementary step in a quantum
computation by putting together many
such
operations you can build up in principle
computations of arbitrary complexity if
you can perform those operations
with sufficient accuracy with good
enough control
so it's nice that technology came along
or was starting to be available
just at the time that we recognized the
potential of quantum computing
and the promise of quantum computing has
continued to drive
the technological developments
which have become more and more
sophisticated
with the goal in mind of scaling up
quantum computers to devices that can
really solve
interesting problems but that technology
can have other spin-offs as well
like better approaches to metrology
more sensitive sensors of various kinds
and potentially to uh the cryptographic
applications as well yeah so these are
all
uh phenomenal applications and i think
some of them are less well-known than
others i am getting
a uh getting another request to have you
move a little bit closer
to the microphone and i think eventually
you'll
you'll give up as you start you know
crashing into the screen of your
computer but
if you can move a little bit closer i
think that would be uh
that would be great i will get closer to
the microphone myself although i am
pretty close as it is right now
um so people are asking about uh yes the
implication for things like quantum
supremacy
uh that has been a term that you coined
and and used i think
probably misunderstood uh first before
we get into
applications or perhaps the prospects
for quantum
supremacy both inside of physics and
maybe outside of
of science altogether in in cryptography
and banking etc
can you explain what uh what you mean by
quantum supremacy
uh and you know how it should be used
maybe how it shouldn't be used what are
your thoughts
uh for the audience about this term that
you coined
many years ago well i think
one of the most remarkable things
that we've understood
about the difference between quantum and
classical systems is
what i made reference to earlier when i
spoke of the quantum
church turing thesis that
we think that in general you can't
efficiently simulate a quantum system
using any classical system
i think that's one of the most
interesting things we've ever
said about how quantum is different from
classical
and so there's a strong incentive to try
to validate that in
the laboratory in a real experiment to
the
extent that we can and so i suggested
that as a challenge
for the field to do experiments
which indicated that we could do
something with the quantum device
which surpasses what we could do with
our most
powerful classical computers
and i called that quantum supremacy um
the concept was not new at the time that
i proposed it of course
but uh i wanted it's nice to have
to frame the challenge in kind of a
concrete way
and uh you know various uh
experimental groups and companies uh
took on that challenge and with some
fanfare the google group
announced in late 2019
that um that they had achieved what uh
they asserted was a demonstration of
quantum supremacy they built a very
interesting piece of hardware
in the google ai quantum lab
based on superconducting technology
not that different from the technology
you use in your detectors
the magic coming from the wonderful
josephson junction
which makes uh makes things sufficiently
non-linear that the quantum physics
becomes
interesting and uh using that
technology they built a device with 53
qubits
and they were able to perform
a sequence of entangling gates which
cause
neighboring qubits in a two-dimensional
array to interact with one another
up to 20 layers of such uh
two cupid gates where in each of those
time steps all of the qubits were
participating
in the gates that were applied and then
they
measured all the qubits and it's a
rather noisy device
far from perfect so when they measure
most of the time they get junk
but maybe a few times out of a thousand
they get a useful result and then they
can run that computation
millions of times in just a few minutes
in order to boost the signal to noise
and get
some statistically useful information
from the experiment and then you could
imagine trying to
simulate what that device is doing
on a classical computer and it's
possible
but it's sufficiently challenging that
that
classical computation would take far
longer than the few minutes that it took
google's device to do the same task so
i like to call it quantum david versus
classical goliath because the
classical supercomputer
covers a couple of basketball courts and
it's using megawatts of power
and google's device is just
you know a little chip in a dilution
refrigerator more of a
desktop scale experiment and yet that
that little chip
is doing something that that big
powerful a supercomputer
um well i can't i wouldn't quite say
can't do
but it would take far longer for the
supercomputer to duplicate
the tasks and so that was more or less
what i envisioned when speaking of
quantum supremacy
now that's not to say that it's of any
practical importance
that that demonstration was achieved the
particular task
that the google device carried out is
not
something that we particularly care
about for any reason other than
demonstrating the quantum supremacy
but i still consider it to be kind of a
milestone
in technology that we've sort of entered
the era
where quantum devices potentially are
capable of doing things that we couldn't
otherwise do
even with our most powerful classical
computers
yeah so one of my uh guests are folks in
the chat room i want to point out we're
talking with
uh legendary physicist the richard
feynman professor of physics at
the california institute of technology
which is a small technical college uh
in pasadena california where i've spent
some my time
uh this is beaver's week on the uh into
the impossible podcast we had frank
wilceck on monday
we had michael saylor mit alum on
uh wednesday or tuesday and wednesday
respectively and now we've got uh beaver
from the west coast
none other than my friend and really a
mentor in many ways
uh that he looks at phys physics the way
that
i would like to someday see it i i call
john kind of the chuck yeager i'm a
pilot john i don't know if you remember
that but
uh all pilots emulate the late great
chuck yeager you know we're talking air
traffic control
machine we're gonna go to the northwest
sector and we're gonna
we try to emulate well physicists we try
to emulate you john
uh you don't have to respond to that but
i am uh i will say the right stuff is
one of my favorite books
and the part about jaeger is the best
part yes it is lovely but
i want to point out we're going to take
some questions now we're raising uh
donations it's not required
by any means but uh for a very lovely uh
uh
program called our institution called
the foothill unity center
this is in southern california and uh i
i think this is a phenomenal
organization
so any of the super chats i will double
the super chats
up to you know uh one bitcoin no i won't
i won't go that high but uh i'll double
it
uh up to you know several hundred
dollars so hopefully we can get that
this is for you know some of the people
who have
great needs in this time of of challenge
and needs and this is the charity that
john
has selected to uh to donate the
proceeds from
this uh generous use of his time
on the into the impossible podcast so
i've got it up on the screen now so
uh we're showing the the organization
you put a donation in the super chat and
i will double it and send it to
the uh the foothill unity center john
thank you for for
or you know alerting me to that uh to
this wonderful cause
uh so going back to to questions from
the audience
one is asked by one of my uh one of my
most loyal guests his his screen name is
six bob ohms uh
and he wants me to ask you about the
physical versus logical number of qubits
for
a useful machine i guess this is what is
the minimum number
of uh physical versus uh logical number
of qubits
for a useful machine that can do you
know things that classical computers
would be less efficient
yeah well let me explain uh
what i think is being asked here in the
distinction between
physical and logical qubit as i
mentioned
in for example this google device
the hardware although impressive
is still quite noisy and that's a
serious limitation
on the scale of the computations that
you can do because if you try to perform
a computation
with hardware that's so imperfect
uh with a large number of qubits or with
many operations with many gates
there will be no signal to noise the
imperfections will completely wipe out
any useful result
and so if we're going to use quantum
computers to solve really hard problems
we have to somehow um
solve that problem to reduce the noise
and potentially
someday we'll be able to do that by
making much much
much better quantum hardware than we
have now i think someday we will do that
but there's another approach which is
more of a software approach
with what we call quantum era correction
and in quantum era correction we
use many physical qubits to represent a
single so-called logical qubit
where the logical qubit is much more
reliable can be manipulated much
more accurately than the single qubit
and just to provide some context
quantum computing is really hard yes and
that's why we've only gotten as far as
we have so far
and there are several things that make
it hard but perhaps the most
formidable problem is what we call
decoherence
which is an important principle in
physics
that of course classical physics is what
we use to describe what we
experience in everyday life and it works
extremely well
and yet underneath it all we think the
world is quantum mechanical
quantum mechanics holds sway at the
scale of
atoms but at the scale of humans it
doesn't seem to be that important
and the reason for that is this
phenomenon of d coherence which makes
quantum systems behave classically
to be well described by classical
physics which is
fine because our lives would be much
stranger if we were
quantum mechanical at a human scale
although i'm sure that would be fun
but for a quantum computer it's really
bad news because
d coherence can make a quantum computer
behave like a classical one and all that
magic that makes the quantum computer
more powerful
would be lost and this decoherence
occurs
because we can't stop the quantum system
or it's very hard to stop the quantum
system from interacting with
the outside world and this is really a
manifestation of the uncertainty
principle in a way
that if you acquire information
about a quantum system then you have to
damage the system
and even if we're not acquiring that
information ourselves if it's leaking
to the outside world to the environment
then
the quantum system will be damaged and
that's going to make our computer
fail so we have to find a way of
overcoming that phenomenon of d
coherence and that's what quantum era
correction
is designed to do and the principle is
that we
can put many qubits together in such a
way
that when the environment interacts with
just a few qubits at a time
the information is extremely well
concealed so it doesn't
easily leak to the outside world
the trouble is that to make that work
effectively
we need many physical qubits to realize
one
very well protected logical qubit and i
think that's
that's what the question is about well
it's about two things really
uh it because i think the question was
how many logical qubits do we need to do
something interesting
and it was at least implicit uh that
that's much different from the number of
physical qubits that we need
and um it's um it's hard to be very
precise
about the first question but
once we have you know of of order
uh 100 cubits or a few
100 cubits and we can do many highly
accurate gates
then that takes us well beyond what we
can simulate with classical computers
and we can envision
uh applications to chemistry for example
if our gates are sufficiently accurate
or simulating materials that could be
done with just a few
hundred of these very well protected
logical cubits but then there's the
question how many
physical qubits do we need for one well
protected
logical qubit and that's also a hard
question to answer precisely because it
depends on several things
one is how accurate is our hardware if
the hardware is so pathetically
uh unreliable uh that
the quantum computer is making mistakes
all the time then quantum error
correction isn't going to work
at all it's not going to give us any
improvement unless
the hardware is good enough and then the
better the hardware gets
the less overhead cost we have to pay
to make a very reliable logical cube
but um you know it's likely
unless cubit technology gets much much
better than it is
now which i think eventually will happen
um
that uh you know we will need
uh potentially hundreds of thousands of
physical qubits for one really well
protected logical qubit so that's pretty
discouraging yeah from the point of view
of the current state of the technology
where you know we maybe will have
devices with the border 100
physical qubits in the near term but we
have to make a very big leap
to uh maybe millions of physical qubits
to get into that regime where we can
perform computations that
are reliable and far surpass what we can
do with our classical computers for
applications people might care about
interesting so i have a question coming
in from ernesto eduardo
dobar ganes and he is asking is there
any
implicit moore's law equivalent for
quantum computing
well um
i don't know um now people have tried to
make a you know to imitate gordon moore
and make a plot of how
quantum computing has has been uh
improving over the last 10 or 20 years
to spot such trends we speak
sometimes a bit jokingly perhaps
about shelkoff's law after rob shelkoff
you probably know rob
i know the name i don't know yeah see uh
he was
a caltech um student who who worked on
uh superconducting devices
sometime back but
you know rob has said that we get
something like uh
an order of magnitude improvement
in the superconducting quantum devices
every
grad student generation over
however many years that is maybe three
or four and that was true for a while
but uh the metric that he and others
used was what we call the coherence time
how long a superconducting qubit
can sit around before it
gets hit by an error and that did
improve
very impressively for a while it might
be slowing down
now already but that's not the only
thing we care about anyway
because we really need
accurate quantum gates and the
coherence time is about storage errors
you know if we put a cubit
in quantum memory and we come back an
hour later
is the qubit still there intact but even
if that's true it doesn't necessarily
mean that we can do
entangling quantum gates on pairs of
qubits
with very high accuracy in fact the
competing technology of trapped ions
the qubits are just wonderful the
cupid's are very well isolated
single atoms and you can prepare a
cubit state in an atom and it will
survive for many hours if you just leave
it alone
but that's not enough for quantum
computing for quantum computing
we need to do these accurate two qubit
gates
and the state of the art is that
there's an error rate per gate under the
best conditions now
of about one in a thousand and
of course we'd like to see that continue
to improve
um but it's hard it's really hard the
whole
it's all hard building a quantum
computer is really challenging
that's my next question uh that comes
from uh someone named brian keating
which is that you know most of the
applications that we have in our
laboratory require you know i always
joke people come to san diego for the
weather
but in the case of our quantum computer
you know capable laboratory
that uses these justin junctions and
squid amplifiers
uh we are the coldest part of you know
san diego to my knowledge although some
elaborate
uh my physics colleagues can go a little
bit cooler but we get down to
six millikelvin six one thousandths of a
degree above absolute zero these are you
know un
incomprehensible temperatures and we're
finally getting some macroscopic you
know cooling powers
of order microwatts you know and
abilities to remove
heats of jewels you know kind of a day
time scale
but um you know what what are kind of
the limits on practical
quantum computers i know you're a
theoretician but but you have a lot of
contact with the experimental community
and obviously you advise many of these
uh
people that are that are attempting to
overcome current limits
is it you know going to take
developments in in
room temperature super connectivity to
have practical quantum computers you
know that we could actually use or
uh or is it you know or are we basically
just going to have a couple of quantum
computers around the world and they'll
do everything
uh you know for the entire planet's
computing needs
well first of all it's important that
there are a lot of
different uh approaches to the
technology
which are advancing in parallel
because we really don't know at present
which technology has
has the best long-term prospects for
scalability
to large devices that can solve
heart problems and they all have their
characteristic
advantages and disadvantages some are
cryogenic
uh like your detectors um
and you know operate at 10 to 20
millikelvin
in a dilution refrigerator but that's
true of the superconducting
devices it's true of some of the
spin qubit technologies where the qubit
resides and
a spin of a single electron it's not
true of
all the technologies or at least not to
the same extent
so in the case of ion traps they can
operate at room temperature
it turns out that they're quieter
they're less noisy
if they run at liquid helium temperature
and about 4 kelvin
and at least some of the ion trappers
are going to go in that direction
to get more reliable hardware
another example is what people call
nv centers which is a defect
in material it could be in diamond
for example and in that case
you can get long coherence times even at
room temperature and that might be
important for some sensing technologies
for example but your
broader question is what do we really
need to advance the hardware
and um there's no single answer to that
in some cases materials advances
are going to be important
that can help with the superconducting
technologies and well
with the spin qubits having more
accurate methods for control
particularly ones which are scalable to
large systems
that's that's also important designing
better qubits
qubits in the case of a superconducting
device
there's a lot of freedom in how we
fashion a cupid out of the ingredients
putting together joseph's injunctions
for example in an electrical circuit
there are a lot of ways to do that
and some of those are more resistant to
noise than others
and so that's another important way to
advance the technology
and and the extreme case of
achieving big progress through
improved materials is what we call
topological quantum computing
which is an idea for realizing materials
that have a kind of intrinsic resistance
to the errors that afflict quantum
hardware
and that in the long run uh could be a
breakthrough technology but like
everything else
it's very hard to achieve yeah i'm
actually getting a question i was about
to ask you
for 20 pounds of british sterling uh
from a friend of ours stefan roche
in the uk and he's asking does john
think that quantum
materials such as topological insulators
or other manifestations of entanglement
in maharana
maharana fermions or in many body
physics can offer more possibilities for
information processing from what you
just said
would seem the answer is yes but
primarily for error correction is that
is that correct
well that's the advantage that
topological materials potentially have
it's a wonderful idea i mean for a
theorist it's an irresistibly beautiful
idea
it came from the fertile imagination of
alexei ketaya
my caltech colleague actually i'll tell
you something funny about that
which maybe says something about me and
also about alexei
so alexi's idea was to take advantage
of something called an eneon
which is a a concept and uh
a word you know which uh frank wilcheck
uh is responsible for
it means particles that have uh
interactions that we call topological
um what does that word topological mean
it means uh
well you know it's topologists uh
talk about properties which uh remain
unchanged when you smoothly deform an
object
um so you know you can't smoothly change
a sphere into a doughnut
and it's very natural to think about
topology in the setting of quantum
computing because we would like the way
we do
our quantum gates the fundamental
quantum operations
to remain invariant when we deform
the hardware by introducing the noise
and um ketaya
proposed this in 1997 and what's funny
is
that over the preceding
eight or so years i had been very
interested
in anions and in particular what we call
non-abelian anions which are the ones
which are
promising from the point of view of
quantum information processing
and then i got very interested in
quantum error correction
how we can make quantum computers robust
in the presence of noise
and somehow i didn't appreciate
that these two ideas are extremely
closely related
that in fact anions can provide an
approach
to doing quantum era correction which
has
some characteristic advantages
did realize that and when i first heard
about the idea
during his first visit to caltech
in 1997 i was immediately excited
because
i was perfectly prepared to appreciate
the idea and how brilliant it was
but i hadn't thought of it myself and so
uh that tells you something about me
and it tells you something about catia
but i guess it also illustrates
uh the principle which is often
applicable that things that seem obvious
in retrospect
are not necessarily obvious at the time
of their discovery
and so that was one of the one of the
things i missed
and uh you know it was just i think uh
a manifestation of my own limitations
yes well we all have uh we all have
blind spots in our education but uh
yours are
very much more narrow than most of our
us mortals but uh so
getting a couple more questions but i do
want to remind folks that we are
raising funds for an extremely worthy
cause close to my heart close to john's
heart
and that's the foothill unity center
which is
located in uh in pasadena let me see if
i can get that up on the screen here
there we go foothill unity center
there we go so very worthy charity with
many great beneficiaries and doing just
a tremendous amount of good in my former
hometown when i was at that technical
college known as caltech
please get involved donate in the super
chat and i will double it we've already
gotten
a tremendous number of donations thank
you so much but we can always use more
so they can do more and it's a very very
important uh
progress project rather for 2021 so help
us
do good my audience is the best in the
known multiverse we're going to turn to
cosmology in a second i do want to
ask folks to please uh to please uh
subscribe to this channel exercise your
fingers regularly
real doctors will tell you to do that
push the subscribe button push the
notification bell hit the thumbs up
button
and that will make folks happy if you're
listening to this on itunes please leave
a review
and a rating because that helps us get
great guests like john you know he looks
at my ratings and reviews
and he decided he would come on finally
because of the
erudition the perspicacity of this
amazing fan base and you could tell john
from the questions we're getting this is
no ordinary
youtube unboxing channel we're going to
unbox a quantum computer
uh next time you come on the show i want
to turn towards cosmology we've had on
folks like
frank wilcek we've had on roger penrose
we've had on leonard milad now and uh
and also
his uh his friend deepak chopra actually
had a conversation
live the four of us deepak chopra myself
frank welchek
and leonard milad now and we talked a
lot about
uh about theories of everything about
the essence of singularities etc
uh the first thing before we take a
detox a deep dive into cosmology
i want to first start uh with a bet that
you made with stephen hawking which
according to
leonard's book on his friendship with
stephen hawking
uh he says uh a bunch of things but he
remarks specifically about you
that nowadays your whole third quarter
course
at caltech for graduate students in
general relativity when you teach it
is just dedicated to hawking radiation
so is that true
or is that false well it was once true i
haven't taught that course for a while
in fact i first taught it gee i don't
know i don't think leonard was around at
the time
um but uh i guess he heard about it
i first taught it in the early 90s and
actually
i was encouraged to do that by kip
thorne
who thought it would be a natural way of
capping our three-term general
relativity
sequence to devote to the third term
after they've already learned
the principles of general relativity and
about properties black holes
to uh the quantum field theory on curve
space-time which is
relevant for understanding hawking
radiation now this was
as is often the case very educational
for me
because although i had some working
knowledge
of the topic you know when you teach a
class
you just get a much deeper understanding
and
so i worked really hard on that class
and um i did teach it a couple more
times
and the goal was to start with
no prior knowledge of
quantum field theory but to the students
were in the third term of a general
relativity sequence so they all knew
something about
general relativity although for this
course you don't need to know that much
about that either
except some appreciation for what a
black hole is and to
starting from nothing more or less uh
arrive
at an explanation for why black holes
emit
hawking radiation so that was a lot of
fun and it deepened my understanding of
that subject and it also
got me more deeply involved in my own
research
in thinking about the quantum behavior
of black holes and
as has often been the case for me and
i'm sure others
the store of knowledge i collected in
the process of
teaching that material is something i've
often drawn on
in my own research in the following
years
so i actually have a bet uh from
theory.caltech.edu
and that is uh whereas stephen hawking
and kip thorne firmly believe
that quantum information that
information swallowed by a black hole is
forever hidden from the
outside universe and can never be
retrieved revealed even as the black
hole evaporates and completely
disappears
and whereas john prescott firmly
believes that a mechanism for the
information
to be released by the evaporating black
hole must and will be found
in the correct theory of quantum gravity
therefore preschool offers and hawking
accepts a wager that
when an initial pure quantum state
undergoes gravitational collapse to form
a black hole
the final state at the end of the black
hole evaporation will be a pure quantum
state
and the lavender is playing an
encyclopedia of the winner's choice
and this is witnessed uh kip thorne john
preschool stephen hawking
6th of february 1997.
so now you won that bet but i want to
push back just gently and always with
respect
and i brought this up to roger penrose
even himself and i want to bring it up
with you
uh i always hear the following we need a
theory of quantum gravity
because at the singularity of
a black hole's core the laws of general
relativity
must break down and the singularity
must therefore be a reflection of the
fact that some other physics is needed
that's
one instantiation of the notion of a
singularity the other one being
the uh the initial singularity that was
uh
believed by hawking and and uh penrose
to be the initiation point of our
current observable universe
i point out uh the following you know
gdankan experiment
what if you get a letter from the old
one
as einstein used to call here come my
finger puppets my voodoo dolls uh
here we go i got one of you but it's on
order it's got two too many pins in it
uh but let's say the old one as einstein
called god
tells you well the big bang might not
have happened as
uh as sir roger newly minted
nobel laureate who left his nobel prize
in my office foolishly
uh but it may not have happened it may
be conformal cyclic cosmology all the
way down
furthermore we have no ability to access
the singularity of a black hole and no
way to get the information out even if
we could access it
so what if there are no singularities
would you still say
we need a theory of quantum gravity
i would say we well whether you needed i
i couldn't say brian but
we want to understand what happens
inside a black hole
it may seem rather exotic well it is
rather exotic let's face it
to consider experiments in which we
enter a black hole and see
what happens to us um and
i think part of the point you're making
is that if we stay outside the black
hole
we won't have at least not in any
obvious way
direct access to the outcome of an
experiment that
occurred inside but you know for all we
know we're inside a black hole now brian
it might be a really really big one and
we're tumbling towards the singularity
and that
would uh you know focus our attention
more
on wanting to understand what happens uh
in the late stages of gravitational
collapse
um whether you want to call it quantum
gravity or not
that's that's just words you just want
to understand
how it works now as far as early
universe cosmology is concerned
i'm a little surprised hearing this from
you
because uh what i hope
you will succeed in doing some day is
finding evidence for primordial
gravitational radiation
from very early in the history of the
universe
and that will of course be a
real milestone in physics and we hope
it will illuminate our understanding
of very early universe cosmology
and that in itself is really quantum
gravity
in a way because we're talking about
gravitational waves that were produced
by quantum fluctuations in the very
early universe at least that's our
current understanding of the explanation
of the signal that you've been looking
for
that's quantum gravity and we hope
that'll
give us some insight into uh
the so to speak initial singularity so
i'm glad you said that
uh it gives me an opportunity to to
tease you
just gently again with respect that the
namesake for which your chaired
professorship is
named is of course richard feynman who
said the first principle is that you
should not fool yourself
no one ever says the second principle
but i think it's
you're the easiest person to fool to
which i added a third one john you'll be
interested to know i'm unveiling it here
for the first time
the third principle is that you must
never fool richard fineman
uh because that would just be mean to
fool richard uh first of all did you
know him well did you uh
did you guys overlap much at all we
overlapped for five years on the caltech
faculty
i arrived in 1983 and uh fineman
passed away in 1988 and we did interact
we had a shared interest in quantum
chromodynamics
the theory of the strong interaction and
in particular
its so-called non-perturbative aspects
that is the things that we can
understand ironically enough just
using feynman diagrams how do we explain
things like core confinement for example
vimeo was very interested in that
so was i uh we often discussed
uh those issues
i uh you know i just as an aside
my first encounter with feynman was not
a face-to-face
encounter it occurred when i was nine
years old
and i acquired a book which was called
the world of science
this was a big golden book about
science and there was a chapter called
theoretical physics
i was a fourth grader i got this book at
a book fair
and i read the chat i read the whole
book it was fascinating in many ways
but the thing that resonated with me the
most at the time
was the chapter on theoretical physics
which discussed the discovery
that parody is violated that physics
in a mirror is different than
physics in real life and that was just
i just found that totally amazing
and in this chapter incidentally there
was also a story about a little boy who
had a ball and a wagon
and he asked his father why the ball
goes to the back of the wagon when he
starts pulling it and it goes to the
front of the wagon when he stops pulling
it
and his father told him well that's
called inertia but nobody knows why
and then years later when fyman did
the uh bbc interview with christopher
sykes
he told that story and i thought what's
going on here
fyman stole that story from that
little golden book well was it a big
golden book that i that i read when i
was nine years old
but i still have the book so i looked
back and i saw that in fact all the
chapters
the authored book was uh named jane
werner
watson and she had gotten every chapter
from interviews with caltech faculty
you wouldn't have known this unless you
looked at the very fine print in the
notes
uh but so of course she had based that
chapter on conversations with feynman
and gelman
who just the book was just really rather
amazing the book was published in 1958
uh parody uh violation had just been
discovered two years earlier
that was the year that feynman and
gelman collaborated
on a famous paper about the theory
of the weak interaction that accounted
for
parody violation and that got into this
golden book about
science and it actually was described
very cogently
what the experimental evidence was for
the violation of parity
and so that really did have an influence
on me i think that i encountered that
book
at that age but anyway uh
feynman um at the time
that i was at caltech he was getting
very interested in quantum computing and
i can tell you why
um it was because of our shared interest
in quantum chromodynamics
and his recognition that
with the methods that were then just
starting out
for studying qcd using
classical computers which are what we
call monte carlo
methods that they had limitations
and there were some problems you just
wouldn't be able to solve
using that type of uh technology that
type of algorithm
he also thought it was going to be a
long time before we'd have
accurate data from those simulations
he was right about that too but this was
part of what stimulated him
to think about the idea of a quantum
computer because he
appreciated that it would be too hard
to simulate something like a collision
between two protons at very high energy
to understand from first principles
in qcd for which we know the right
equations but they're just too hard to
solve
what comes out when you bang two protons
together
and that um i think was
a key feature in guiding him towards
proposing the idea of a quantum computer
to solve problems that would be too hard
to solve otherwise
when i think about that uh his
prescience and all things and gravity
and nanotechnology his famous plenty of
room at the bottom
lecture but also that that you know kind
of principle against confirmation bias
and the notion of you know you're the
easiest person to fool and that
scientists often give off this aura of
invincibility which i think
you know i talked at this conversation
with caltech uh postdoc
alum uh jim gates who i know you know
very well he's a good friend of mine
and uh and a mentor to me and millions
of other people and
jim was saying look there's this notion
that einstein is some
you know unapproachable genius and he's
like einstein wasn't always einstein and
you know but i feel like feynman might
have always been feinman he he had this
kind of
you know otherworldly almost magical uh
ability to both
communicate science but also to develop
and
innovate in science in a very artistic
showman-like way
and uh the only reason i bring up that
that famous quote against confirmation
bias is because you said you know
i hope that you'll be successful in
discovering it lately i've been thinking
a lot about that
and how it of course led to the famous
episode in my book uh behind me losing
the nobel prize
which you can get uh wherever books are
sold i'm i'm waiting for
for uh john's book to come out so i can
also hawk his book when that does uh
appear in quantum computing
but uh but the point being that you know
oftentimes you you see what you want to
see
and as feynman was saying that uh
scientists
have this extra special duty because the
layperson
sees us as these very special people
doing very special things
uh with very special equipment and that
maybe they don't have access to it but
they're certainly interested in it but
you know i'm not sure i could ask
somebody like richard feynman this
question but it's just amazing to hear
the story of you as a nine-year-old
this through line carrying through to
the little boy becoming the feynman
professor at caltech it's just
astounding to me
the serendipity of it all and i think
that is you know kind of a back you know
a basis for a lot of good sciences
is that you see where your curiosity
takes you but getting back to
this notion of quantum matter and and uh
quark matter etc
so i asked this a frank wilczak earlier
this week i would like to get your
um your impression i i said to me one of
the most beautiful
experiments ever done is the aharonov
balm effect
because it really does this magical kind
of
connection between the classical world
and the quantum world
and it also connects things that we
thought had no physical
import namely the vector potential and
it makes it
manifest in an actual classical physical
experiment which again can be manifest
in quantum scales too
that to me is one of the most beautiful
experiments the cs wu matamu
experiment that revealed uh parody
violation that you just talked about as
a
as a young child that you read about uh
what to you i'll tell you what frank
said but i want to know what
uh what john is your most beautiful
experiment
coming from the perspective of a
renowned theorist
what makes an experiment beautiful and
what experiments do you particularly
find important and beautiful
well just to follow up on the har no
poem example which is of course a
wonderful example one of the things that
i think is really cool
about that is that you can
observe the harno foam effect
in a solid-state device in which an
electron
follows one of two paths even though
it's kind of dirty and the electron gets
scattered
in the device because of the dirt but it
because it gets scattered
elastically because by being scattered
it doesn't leave
any footprints in the material
there's no record of which way it went
and so you have to consider
the quantum mechanical superposition
of two paths even though that electron
was not perfectly isolated from other
stuff
it was getting bumped around but it in
getting bumped around
it didn't um it didn't leave any record
and therefore that quantum mechanical
interference was possible
um i'm not sure what i think is the most
beautiful experiment but
um well i already i already made
reference
to the fact which you know i think is um
is quite amazing uh that
we can manipulate single atoms now with
extraordinary
precision thanks to
laser technology yeah so you know it's
it's often the case
that in order to make scientific
progress
we need new ideas but we also need new
technology
and in order to do the things that
people do
nowadays manipulating
single atoms or interactions between
pairs of atoms
with laser light for example
it requires you know very sophisticated
laser technology you need very quiet
stable lasers uh to do that
and um you know these are it's just a
single atom for christ's sake
uh and yet it you can make it very uh
you know very palpable uh you can make
it do what you wanted to do
because we have the technology for that
i think that
if you step back and think about it is
pretty amazing
yeah it certainly is i want to segue um
into something related to what frank
answered which was the
uh the not physically beautiful
necessarily but the fact that qcd
uh can be revealed or asymptotic freedom
etc can be revealed by
these quark jets that come out that
reveal the internal composition
of of um uh of the
structure of the nucleon which i think
is uh which is which is quite amazing
i want to take a break and then i'm
going to come right back to that i don't
know how much more time do you have
today john
well i'm still having fun me too i want
to keep going uh
if we can um so the question that i have
well first let me just take a break
please like and subscribe and comment
etc on this video on this uh
podcast on itunes it really helps us in
our mission to
connect the multiverse of minds around
uh
around these very high level deep
conversations that hopefully are
accessible to people too so
exercise your finger regularly push the
like uh push to subscribe
uh give a rating etc also please note i
am taking all your donations
my friend and moderator jacob kuhn who's
just a hilarious and
helpful uh sprite who's who's doing such
a good job he's keeping track of every
donation i am going to double it it's
going to the foothill center
in uh pasadena which is a cause near and
dear to my heart and to john's as well
so please
keep the super chats coming i'll try to
get to as many of them as i can
um and um uh and you know
and we'll hopefully raise uh a lot of
great
uh a lot of great uh resources for this
wonderful charity
so and that can be helpful can i follow
up on what you were saying about jets
and qcd
because uh i mean there's a feynman
story here too
right which goes back to about uh 1968
when uh you know there were these
mysterious
uh scaling results seen
at in the slack uh electroproduction
experiments and
trying to figure out what was going on
feynman developed what he called the
part-time
model it infuriated murray gelman by the
way that he
called them photons instead of quarks
but at any rate
uh he anticipated
that in a high-energy collision
of protons if you hit a quark he called
it a part-time if you hit it really
hard you could produce
a uh you know a pair of leading quarks
going in
opposite directions which although you
wouldn't be able to detect the single
quark would produce a spray
of strongly interacting particles which
could be detected
now this was actually an absurd idea
because
there are very strong interactions
inside the proton and the quarks can't
get out and he was pretending they were
just like free particles
um and uh there were some people who uh
who ridiculed the idea for that
example i might as well name names
murray
uh thought it was you know amazingly
unsophisticated
to uh to treat those quarks as though
they were free particles
whereas obviously they couldn't be
because they were trapped
inside the proton and yet
as experiments validated
the picture is pretty accurate now of
course the reason
the picture makes sense is because of
asymptotic freedom in 1968
or nine uh fyma didn't know that
uh but nevertheless he had the uh the
boldness and intuition
uh to propose that for some purposes the
things rattling around inside
a proton would behave like they were
nearly free
and of course later on we understood the
theoretical foundation
of that picture that's right i'm getting
a quote from one of my uh
good friends and very devoted followers
brett harris who makes a joke that those
were
of course feinman being the womanizer he
was name those after
dolly parton uh so uh
so the next comment i want to make about
relevant to jets and and frank
wilcheck's
statement that that's the most beautiful
experiment to him of course you know he
he had also associated with his uh his
gildan uh medallion that that he
achieved as well but to me
i want to connect it to something which
is tangentially perhaps related to
quantum
computing and i know you're going to get
mad at me but i have to say it
the simulation hypothesis so there is
this notion that quantum computing will
become so powerful
it will be way beyond supremacy and
it'll be something that we can hardly
envision today just as
you know einstein could not have
envisioned an iphone and us having this
conversation
essentially at the speed of light taking
questions from pakistan
and uganda at the same time as in la
jolla and
uh pasadena but uh but the concept of of
the simulation hypothesis is as nick
balstrom and others have popularized it
that
eventually will reach this incredible
power of a.i
and so it might even have occurred
already and that you and i as you said
before we might be inside the black
holes
event horizon now uh plummeting
furiously towards the singularity
but in the notion that we would be
unaware of it and so in that same sense
as
um as descartes would say you know we
could be brains in jars
we could be brains in a computer and a
quantum computer so first i want to ask
you
what do you think about this simulation
hypothesis do you put any
uh stock in it and then if you're
willing to i'd love to talk about
some of the implications the moral and
ethical implications of artificial
intelligence
if such a scenario is at all plausible
in john preschool's mind
well i've limited interest in it unless
we can somehow validate it
you know if we had a way of doing an
experiment
which would uh yield a result that would
say aha
we are in a simulation or we are not
that would certainly be interesting um
and uh there have been some suggestions
along those lines although
rather crude ones when we try to
simulate
uh an imaginary world on our computers
we can't do it perfectly so for example
if i wanted to
do it if you wanted to simulate quantum
chromodynamics
you uh it's a quantum field theory and
that means you have an infinite number
of degrees of freedom for unit volume
and you can never put that on a computer
so you approximate it and you
approximate it by just introducing some
lattice in space
or doing some other what we call
regularization some truncation of the
problem and that means
that the results don't exactly agree
with the target that we're trying to
simulate so if
our hypothetical higher beings
who might be simulating our world have
similar
limitations if we could somehow find
evidence
for the imperfections in their
simulations
um i'm not sure how but that would be
interesting so in fact you can uh
you know people have i tried to get
limits on the uh
the possibility that um you know space
isn't a continuum but is really
an approximation some kind of lattice
structure how
can we probe that in an experiment well
that's somewhat interesting to think
about
yeah i'm sure but if it's you know if
it's purely hypothetical and then we
don't have a way
of testing it then i just can't get that
interesting yeah i'm showing on the
screen now a paper by silas bean
uh zoray davouti and martin savage
called constraints on the universe as a
numerical simulation
and they're examining these uh
consequences of a cubic space-time
lattice or grid
being explored in the qcd lattice
simulations so using historical
development of lattice gauge theory
technology as a guide we assume our
universe
is an early numerical simulation with
unimproved wilson fermion discretization
i don't know what that means but
we investigate potentially observable
consequences among the observables that
are considered as g minus two
and the spectrum of cosmic rays um and
so forth so there are
you know forays into it i wonder always
you know how how fruitful this will be
but uh eventually i think you know this
this can be
uh in a manifestation of of perhaps
deeper questions maybe that go outside
of science even into
perhaps religion you know because if you
think about
the universe as a simulation maybe there
are simulators
uh maybe there's artificial uh life out
there as max tegmark calls it as life
3.0 and then my question is what
obligation do we humans have to these
artificial intelligence can we turn them
off
can we blow up one of their capacitors
so i want to turn to artificial
intelligence for a little bit
um and and ask you know about about the
prospects for
improvements in ai and also you've
talked about this
before i always say it's it's not
surprising so surprising to me that
computers can beat humans
at chess even the alpha zero results
where it basically learns the rules of
chess from
millions and trillions of games watched
by played by humans
and then playing itself and even learn
the pieces and how they move and that a
knight moves a different way than a
bishop
but what would really surprise me and
convince me that
computers have artificial wisdom is if
they could create
the game of chess itself or you know if
there's a lot of art now that i'm told
exist on the blockchain there's actually
blockchain art that
exists that you can buy it and it exists
and you get it on a usb
key if you want it 50 megabytes worth of
beautiful hand create
computer created art i want to ask you
um
these notions of artificial intelligence
do you think a computer can ever create
a game like chess or
even chess itself and and then i want to
ask you a follow-up about
the laws of physics can a computer can
an artificial intelligence
eventually just given the laws of newton
derive the laws of einstein but first
tell me what what are your thoughts
about artificial intelligence and its
future
and the limitations possibly thereof
well i don't see any reason why not
in answer to your question can
artificial intelligence
be creative uh can it discover
things that have escaped uh the astute
humans that seems likely to me uh
as artificial intelligence continues
to advance and part of the reason i say
that is
i think you and i are ourselves
just sophisticated machines i don't
think i don't believe that there is
magic in human cognition
i think it's a kind of emergent
phenomenon
that occurs in a sufficiently
complicated
network of neurons and if it can happen
in our brains
i don't see why it can't happen in
devices that
engineers build um
sorry what was that rest of the question
well can a computer yeah create the game
of chess
or a game you know what i'd like to see
them do is is be funny
you know why can't they create a great
sitcom
that's art for uh for that we all would
need right now
i think you know as much of a joke as i
am but it still would be great to have
you know people have i have fooled
around uh getting
um ai systems to uh
to create uh visual art and to write
poetry
and uh you know so far
i'm not uh really impressed but you know
that'll get better and better so again
we're talking with john presquez feynman
professor of physics california
institute of technology caltech go
beavers
uh spent many a wonderful lectures
listening to john
uh both up at caltech and here at uc san
diego where he's given
some of our prized lectures uh sticking
on the theme of artificial intelligence
as you know my uh my friend max tegmark
has done a lot of work in this he's a
guest on the show
frequent guest on the show and um that
reminds me to ask you all out there to
please subscribe because max is coming
back again
uh for on the into the impossible
podcast but he talks about
you know creating artificial uh
physicists
and and my question to you is let's say
now now i've got my voodoo doll out this
is galileo
um so you know galileo did something and
and then newton came along and did
something even better
uh but there's something different in my
mind between what you know newton did to
galileo
and and his laws of motion and what
einstein did it's a fundamentally
different characteristic class so i can
almost imagine
a computer program with the laws of
newtonian physics
or the laws of galilean relativity
coming up with newtonian mechanics
but it's harder for me to think about a
computer coming up just with the
lacuna in the data that uh general
relativity
patched up the perihelion anomaly of
mercury etc
that a computer could come up with gr uh
as an artificial physicist what do you
what do you think about this because i i
have
i have some desires in pedagogy that i
want to talk to you about right after
this but but
tell me what are your thoughts about the
the nature of physics is it like coming
up with good stand-up
you know comedy or is it is it something
that physics that computers couldn't do
where do you get those einstein and
galileo
don't worry yes i i have a team of of
little
of of little servants at home that are
no no i i buy them from a place called
the unemployed philosophers guild
they're called magnetic personnel i've
got one of everyone i've got a i got
carl sagan here
i've got uh noam chomsky who's also been
a guest on the show
i've got kurt gordle who has not been a
guest on the show that would be
that would be quite a get uh i will send
you some john i'll send you an einstein
and we got to get one of fine men and
one of you
but uh can't those really come in handy
don't they
good good pawn john come in handy i like
it yeah exactly you know it
uh it's interesting you mentioned
goodell because he's sort of relevant to
your question
perhaps you know the notion
that uh there's a distinction
to be made between things that
we can easily verify through thought or
computation and the things that we can
discover
uh what the computer scientists call the
conjecture that p
is not equal to np um
goodall thought about this quite some
time ago
like in the 1950s and uh
he was very curious about
um what it would mean
if p is equal to np that would mean that
anything that um you know you could buy
some feasible computation
check would be something that uh that
you could discover
and he found this idea rather
distressing because it indicated to him
that
there was no role for the creativity
of the mathematician who somehow by some
mysterious process was able to discover
a theorem
which for which a proof could be given
and it was
possible for any diligent uh party to
check that the proof was correct
but to come up with the theorem in the
first place
required a leap of creativity
and um so
you know some might believe and maybe
did you discuss this with roger because
he has uh
interesting views on this kind of thing
yeah yeah we certainly did and i talked
about it with with uh
nom chomsky as well uh this this notion
of you know kind of incompleteness
um and i feel you know there's an old
joke that
most sciences have physics envy but i
actually think physicists have
mathematician envy
in a sense that we don't have a law that
tells us
whether or not something is physics i
mean most of us use popper
i think i have a popper doll somewhere
but um your friend
lenny suskind you know said don't be
overwhelmed by the paparazzi you know
basically
these unfalsifiable you know kind of
cudgels
that physicists get hit with are not as
useful as
as girdles incompleteness theorem is to
mathematics so i i joke that yeah we
have
mathematician envy in a sense and i
think
roger to some extent agrees well anyway
to come back to your question
um it's my
belief that
the leap that zayn einstein made by
discovering general relativity
on the basis of rather paltry
experimental evidence at the time is
something that
an artificial intelligence system should
eventually be able to do because i don't
think
einstein or other human physicists and
mathematicians
are super superhuman
they are i think they're machines too so
i i think they're just very
sophisticated and effective machines now
incidentally
the discovery of general relativity was
not something that sprung
from einstein's mind
in its full glory instantaneously it was
the result
of a struggle that went on for years
and in which there were many wrong turns
yeah
but you know he was able just on
theoretical grounds
to uh to find the way because
various things that he tried uh
seemed not to work and uh
so you know uh the
circumstances were such that it was
possible to find
one's way to that discovery through uh
of course uh enormous uh a creative
genius
but also a kind of process of trial and
error
until he hit on the right thing yeah it
is
uh coin kind of and it wasn't ever it
took
you know five years to come up with uh
to come up with the final formulation
and then even in its final formulation
he had the cosmological term
which he you know uh apocryphally called
a blunder but he really didn't
but still it was a blunder to even think
it was a blunder because of course in 97
98 we realized we needed
uh dark energy or some cosmological like
acceleration to explain the
anomalous acceleration of uh expansion
of the universe
uh that uh former guest adam reese
talked about on the show
uh earlier this summer it's funny
because i i get a lot of emails i'm sure
you do too
i'm actually getting some right now
let's say you know professor keating
einstein was wrong uh you know i can
prove it i'm not so good at math but
if you help me i will share the nobel
prize with you
you know at least a third of the nobel
prize i'll share that with you but you
got to help me do it
but he was wrong and i told that to adam
reese and he said yeah how do you think
i won my nobel prize
well you know einstein did make blunders
and in the case of the cosmological
constant
i mean i've always felt that the blunder
was
not that he proposed it which was a
perfectly reasonable thing to do
uh it's a personally sensible thing to
add
to the equations in fact from our modern
point of view
it's very hard to understand why it
wouldn't be there or even why it would
be as small as it's observed to be
the blunder was that his motivation for
doing so was to make the universe status
and it's unstable yeah and he never
bothered to check because
haley says not mentioned in his paper
that
he was balancing the universe like a
pencil on its point
uh it wouldn't you know you gave it a
little nudge and it would not stay
yeah so uh mario olivio who you may know
has written uh
many many books uh the golden ratio is
got a mathematician i think or maybe
someone else wrote that but he wrote a
book recently brilliant blunders
and also a book about creativity uh we
talked about you know even darwin had
blunders
galileo certainly had some huge whoppers
you know he
he missed the discovery of the planet
neptune he
uh he thought the earth's tides i don't
know if you've ever seen this book or
read this book john i had not read it
until very recently
uh this is a book that uh is called the
dialogue on the two chief world systems
and there's a forward by stephen jay
gould and so far there's a forward by
albert einstein who calls it one of the
greatest books in
in in science history much better than
than even
newton's principia which is almost
unreadable even for a lay person
uh but certainly uh even for a physicist
certainly for many lay people
but in that book the original title for
the book called
the dialogue was i don't know if you do
you know what the original title that
galileo wanted for this book
i do know it was on the flux and reflux
of tides in oceans rivers and
ferns i don't know what a fern is maybe
you do but but
um that was really burying the lead
wasn't it but actually that was what he
thought was the most
uh pronounced evidence for the
copernican theory and of course it's
totally wrong the tides are caused by
the earth's moon not the earth's motion
uh and so the catholic church
did him a favor they prohibit him to use
that title maybe they thought the
evidence was overwhelming but it really
goes to show
you know great men and great women are
capable of making great mistakes
i wonder we have this image of richard
feynman
as ineffable as unfailing as you know
prescient beyond
human mortal comprehension is there a
blunder that he made i have eight
different blunders that einstein made
ranging from you know
spooky action at a distance to the
cosmological constant
even the his original paper and
relativity contained uh
a misassociation of energy and mass i
mean
he went on to have an okay career okay
i'm not really
gonna gonna assail him too much but did
feynman have any blunders
i'm not i'm not particularly aware he
didn't he didn't you know get credit for
things like quarks
but that was that was not a blunder per
se do you know of any like mistakes or
whoppers that he might have made
not in his publications that come to
mind he was fallible
and i think uh he was certainly capable
of being wrong
in uh physics discussions that i recall
now i should
add the um you know the qualifier that
that i uh started to to have
scientific discussions with feynman when
he was um
you know in the 60s and
the feynman of earlier decades
might have given a different impression
but um
he would sometimes surprise me um
because he had some ideas about
renormalization for example
that i thought were um we're a little
behind the times and unsophisticated you
know
feynman often uh said
or they would give the advice that um
you know don't pay attention to what
other people say uh
you know put their papers away and work
it out for yourself
and there's something to be said for
that of course you know when you really
work it out you own it
but it's not very good advice uh it's
bad advice it wouldn't be very good
advice for me
and it's not very good advice for most
students
because you know the people who uh who
worked on problems ahead of you are not
all idiots and
you can learn a lot by studying their
work of course
you want to be able to internalize it to
the extent that you can reproduce it
and i think feynman in the years that i
knew him suffered a bit
from his attitude that uh you know he
wasn't so interested
in what others working on similar
problems
had to say as i mentioned earlier we
worked
uh well we did we discussed we never
wrote a paper or anything
but we used to discuss court confinement
and how to think about it
and there were there were very
insightful papers on the topic
uh by for example polyakoff
and uh two of my
physics heroes and um which
you know feynman well i in discussions
he thought i was brilliant because i was
able to share the insights i had learned
by reading those papers but you know he
would have
he would have benefited if he had been
more open to following the literature at
that stage
yeah and he could have had a good career
um
i want to uh to take a couple questions
from the audience if you'll
uh if you'll uh indulge me on this this
is a very technical question again i
have a brilliant audience
of a fellow geeks nerds and dweebs all
around the world
and this one is going to come from uh
another one from brett harris this is in
aussie
dollars which i think are miniature
dollars i'm not sure but uh brett asks
uh
loop quantum gravity implies the horizon
of a black hole contains the information
in area eigenstates could there be
literally nothing inside the event
horizon
including the absence of space time
itself
it's a very interesting question and it
has
been a topic of some controversy
in recent years uh i think um
well you know you asked about the
singularity or
um and it's true we
don't have anything close to a
satisfying
theoretical understanding of what
happens at the singularity inside a
black hole the horizon itself
is also very interesting um
from the point of view of quantum
gravity
and in fact uh you mentioned the bet
earlier
that i had with stephen about what
happens to information that's right that
falls into a black hole
and his intuition
that a black hole would destroy
information
was not well in the singularity had
something to do with it
but one could uh understand where he was
coming from just thinking about the
event horizon
that stuff would fall into a black hole
and it didn't have any way of getting
out
and oh he had disc now that wouldn't
itself uh necessarily
mean that information gets destroyed
were it not for the effect of hawking
radiation which he discovered
which means that a black hole radiates
away its mass and eventually
could disappear entirely so if you throw
some precious information
encoded in your diary or something like
that into a black hole
then if that black hole evaporates and
disappears it seems that that
information is
from then on permanently concealed from
any
possible observer and it was
that kind of picture that led to him to
argue that information
is lost our current
understanding and i would not claim that
we have at all a complete understanding
of how it works
is that the information encoded in that
diary does get revealed by the hawking
radiation itself but in a very very
highly scrambled form which is hard to
read
and in order to understand how that
works we don't necessarily have to
contemplate what happens
at the singularity and in fact that's
part of the reason
that addressing the question of
information lost by black holes hasn't
taught us much about the singularity
right but i think we have gotten a lot
of insight
into how information can leak out of a
black hole
by understanding more deeply what's
happening in the vicinity of the event
for us
so just to uh so i've taken on a new
uh a new component of the into the
impossible podcast again everybody
stretch your fingers
it's been a nice long 94 minutes so far
we're gonna keep going for a few more
minutes until
i get overwhelmed with hunger and start
to eat uh
one of these one of these finger puppets
on my desk but please do subscribe like
and leave a comment uh what you're
learning from this episode
uh and and hopefully we can get john
back for a part two someday
uh but uh on one of my components of the
into the impossible podcast
i ask authors uh if they're willing to
do the following
to read the highest and lowest reviews
that they've gotten on their book or
project on amazon
a lot of people like to do that some
people are scared to do that
uh they don't want to hear the one star
reviews and so yeah i
sometimes will not uh will not press the
issue since your book is not
out yet when is your book on quantum
computing coming out john
i don't know i have infinitely
patient uh editors at cambridge
university perhaps
well whenever it comes out i'm sorry for
delaying it for almost two hours now but
we'll continue but anyway i'm getting to
this you know the urdosh apparently said
uh he was incredibly productive but once
his students got very concerned
because he was uh basically doing
amphetamines every day
he would take some form of caffeine and
amphetamines
and that they implored him they said you
have to stop you're addicted he said i'm
not addicted i can stop any time
he stopped and they said stop for a
month so he stopped for a month
at the end of the month he came back and
he said uh you have congratulations
i've done it but you've set mathematics
back exactly
one month so this conversation is
setting back
uh quantum computing textbooks exactly
two hours uh hopefully
but i want to push back uh from a
colleague by the name of sabine
hossenfelder i don't know if you know
sabine
but she claims the black hole
information loss paradox is one of the
biggest
hyped problems and waste of time in all
of physics
it's been solved multiple times it's not
been solved it can't be solved
because existing technology she says i'm
reading from some of her tweets
uh because the hawking temperature of
the known black holes is too low to see
them evaporating
and even if we did see them evaporating
wouldn't tell us anything about
information
laws so how do you respond to that uh
given that you know a lot of
this this kind of notoriety at least
that hawking got was based on you know
in part this bet that the two of you
wagered together
well i think sabine is too pessimistic
um i i mean i understand where she's
coming from i think
um physics advances
by um the interplay of theory and
experiment and
she's expressing the concern and that
we're speculating
about phenomena that we don't have a
means of exploring
experimentally
and so we're limited we're
uh constrained to try to attack the
problem
just by pure thought and she just
doesn't believe we can make progress
that way
yeah i think we actually have made a lot
of progress
and in fact um i'm hopeful
that we can accelerate that progress
eventually coming back to the topic at
the beginning of this discussion
by simulating phenomena like
the formation and evaporation of a black
hole
using quantum computers and we
understand
i think and this is one of the signals
of progress in recent
years what that would mean how we would
do it
and the um what has been the foundation
of much of our progress on understanding
quantum gravity for over 20 years
is what we call holographic duality
um one of your earlier guests uh
actually did you have one maldoceno on
your yes i did
and lenny suskin which i'll get to so
you had lenny and juan and lenny and
really conceived the holographic
principle
and juan uh discovered
in 1997 a uh manifestation of it
which we've continued to pursue and
think about and it's i think it's led to
quite
remarkable insights and it concerns
the um importance of quantum
entanglement
in fact what this holographic duality is
about in the form
that uh that maldasena formulated
is that we can in a particular type of
space-time which unfortunately isn't the
one we live in so it's kind of the prime
model
anti-sitter space we can explore
gravitational phenomena in which quantum
effects are
important by using ordinary
quantum mechanics describing
behavior at the boundary of that space
time in in fact a space of one
lower dimension and so somehow this bulk
evolution of geometry um
is encoded in that boundary and how is
it encoded
it's encoded in the structure of the
quantum entanglement
in that boundary description so we have
these two
different ways of describing the same
physical phenomena they look very
different
but there's a dictionary that relates
the description
in one formulation with the description
on the other and that's very
empowering because you can make use of
that dictionary to get
insights which would otherwise be very
elusive
and what we are learning from that is
that we should think of the geometry
of space itself in the context of
quantum gravity as a kind of emergent
phenomenon
it's really a manifestation of quantum
entanglement in a sense which we
partially
understand and uh what we haven't
understood very well so far
is how to think about what happens
to brian keating when he daringly
enters a black hole and crosses the
event horizon
and what he experiences in the black
hole interior
we still have a limited understanding of
that and
in particular of what happens at the
singularity as we discussed earlier but
i think
really amazing insights are occurring
and when it comes to experiment since we
now understand that in a way this
quantum gravity can be described by
ordinary quantum mechanics that's
something we can simulate with quantum
computers
and i'm hopeful although it's not going
to happen in the next 10 years
in a few decades i'm hopeful that we'll
get real insights
into quantum gravity by doing such
experiments and we wouldn't have thought
of doing those experiments
if we had followed
sabine's instructions
to not bother to think about it because
we'll never figure it out
yeah i had that discussion with uh lenny
uh
exactly about this very topic and it
surprised me i mean
i asked him what is the most you know
quantum aspect
of a black hole in totality is it the
singularity
and he said no it's the stretched
horizon that he sort of i believe coined
the term about and that how much we're
learning about quantum gravity and the
potential for quantum gravity
from it um of course yeah uh that
that dovetailed in nicely with uh with
the conversation
with cameron baffa as well that you know
essentially that we're learning more and
more about
concepts like quantum gravity like even
string theory um
from potentially from observations of
black holes even with
your colleagues at caltech and ligo um
instrumentation they i've had ray weiss
on and barry barish
and you know they think there might be
clues that we could get to the nature
quantum nature of black holes even from
instruments maybe successors to ligo if
not ligo itself so i think and there are
people working on
uh current generation gravitational wave
instrumentation to detect quantum
properties of black holes so let me put
in a word for my friend uh kip
thorne have you tried to keep on your
show yes kip is amazing he's blown me
off uh three times but always as a
gentleman
and he has a great reason for it which i
i'll summarize in
and and by just saying he's he's never
been so
uh productive he claims during as during
covid and that the covid
uh emergency which is tragic and and
awful
has afforded him the opportunity to say
no to
uh you know schmendricks like me so
he's declining everything i guess he and
ray and barry are working on a book
about ligo
uh so he's occupied by that but i was
just going to say the the notion of a
stretched horizon as sort of a living
breathing thing
uh this was kip's idea wow that he
developed
with his uh students um
i guess in the 1980s they wrote a book
about it in fact but they were thinking
about black holes
as classical objects for the most part
although they had some ideas about their
quantum behavior as well and
pointed out you know you can think of
the horizon as having physical
properties
like viscosity and electrical
conductivity
and i think that was that helped to
inspire
lenny's um quantum version of the
stretched horizon
and incidentally you know since you
mentioned ligo and i'm from caltech of
course
um maybe that should have been my answer
to the most beautiful experiment because
golly just think about it you know a
couple of black holes
merge billions and billions of years ago
and today a wave washes over the earth
that stretches and contracts the earth
by about the size of an atomic nucleus
and an instrument can detect that i mean
that's just such a wonderful scenario oh
yes it is
uh quite phenomenal and especially the
technological challenges and the and the
uh the story behind it
almost getting canceled many times and
kind of emerging from an unlikely
team of rivals between rival beavers as
we described earlier
um so i have a quick question for you
from ernesto eduardo de marginis again
uh thank you so much ernesto he's asking
a very simple question what happens to a
lagrange point
such as l1 when two black holes merge
nice so i guess it's a question about uh
the orbits
around the black holes i don't think
it's really a general relativity
question
um it's a question about uh you know
orbital mechanics
well okay maybe it's why maybe it's a
question about general relativity
because you can't uh
you can't ignore curvature uh for the
uh for the orbits he's talking about
um well it's already complicated when
you have two black holes right
well i guess i should confess i don't
really know exactly
yeah i assume your colleague sterl
finney could could uh
present some approach i'll try to get
sterlon to answer that question ernesto
thank you
uh and a question as we kind of wrap up
uh that i've always wanted to ask you
i've asked this of sean
uh carol who's your caltech colleague
he's been on the show multiple times
and that is whether or not um you know
these mathematical objects are real
in the sense that uh we talk about uh
reality materialism etc uh you know
sean's given many talks about concepts
like god
religion etc that they are less likely
to be true because there are simpler
entities and universes that could be
imagined
and are not instantiated such as a
hilbert space with no
objects within it before we get to like
you know maybe
the politics and and god a section of
this podcast
i want to ask you is is hilbert space
real
is it does it exist uh does it predate
the universe
what's your notion of of the reality
uh which came first the hilbert space or
the egg universe
well i guess that's pretty deep question
i should say
when it comes to mathematics um
my view is that
maybe it's a little bit iconoclastic i'm
not sure
is that what's true and false
in mathematics is in a sense a question
about physics
what do i mean by that i mean
mathematicians are interested in what
they can prove
and a proof is something that you can
verify and the verification
is some kind of physical process so you
can always formulate it
in the form of you know some experiment
that you do
by manipulating objects maybe it's
running a
computer program and you can check all
the steps
and see if they you know follow within
the logical system
uh that that you formulated now you know
the
the set there is have these wild
imaginations
and invent incredible you know trans
finite uh
worlds that seem far beyond the world we
can ever experience
but nevertheless they make statements
about those which
are logically
verifiable and that verification is
something i would think of
as in the domain of physics because it's
some machine or something uh the checks
that the steps are really
really consistent with the rules as for
does hilbert space really exist
um well yeah it's a good question
we have a growing prejudice which i sort
of referred to
uh among those who study quantum gravity
that space is an effective
concept not it's it's emergent it's not
you know really at the uh at the bottom
of things that under the right
conditions uh something that we can
describe as space as we study it in
ordinary
particle physics in particular with a
finite speed of light
uh you know that that emerges as an
approximation from some more fundamental
description
and uh i mentioned the idea of
holographic duality that's sort of a
manifestation of that in a certain
setting that there really are things
that happen there which are
non-local which you might think of as
you know information traveling faster
than light but it's still a very very
good approximation under the right
conditions
to use our usual rules of
einstein's space-time
um i don't i'm not aware
of a similar deeper description in which
hilbert's space is emergent
that i have found leads to
um useful insights so
i certainly can't rule it out um
and but as of now
i not aware of a good incentive
to think of hilbert's space as a
merchant maybe sean would disagree with
me
yes he does put a lot of uh stock in in
hilbert space
as i've come to realize over time
uh so we are going to wrap up soon i
want to make one
last uh uh plea to
please uh be generous with your
donations
to the foothill community center i'll
put this back up
on the screen so that you may gaze upon
this wonderful organization that john
and i are raising funds for we've had
uh over almost a hundred dollars that
will be donated so far i'd love to even
up that maybe even double it uh thank
you so much for your generosity to my
uh just my cherished audience i love you
guys
and look stay tuned for many more
wonderful interviews
uh with intellects we didn't get to any
of the quantum
computing fundamental physics links john
i hope we'll be able to do a part two at
some point
uh maybe with gerard or or you know
maybe we'll do with lenny
we'll get some some uh he'll get a live
stream
cage match between friends maybe sabine
i'll get sabina in here that'll be fun
i know my audience would like to see
that she doesn't like to debate
anymore we did do a debate this summer
about theories of everything with max
tegmark lee smallin
stefan alexander lisa randall
sabina eric weinstein uh and i
believe i didn't miss anybody out and
that was really fun but she said that's
basically the last time she's going to
do a live
a live chat like that not because she
had a bad time but just
she feels her energy is best used
elsewhere but anyway um i'd love to get
you back to actually talk about the
uh uh fundamental physics implications
and
and opportunities that quantum quantum
computing could provide so maybe on the
you know before your book comes out i'll
use it as a as a
as a marketing tool to get to get more
attention to your
uh to your book which i can't wait to
get my hands on get a signed copy
like i gave you a signed copy of losing
the nobel prize not too long ago
all right so john the last uh three
questions i ask
my uh my uh uh my cherished guests
involve uh basically arthur c clarke in
one form or another
and that is uh really thinking about the
future and thinking about the past
advice
to your former self but i'll ask you the
first one which actually comes from my
religion of judaism
which is uh known originally as an
ethical will or a
zava ah and it's not too dissimilar to
from what
uh good old alfred nobel did when he
endowed this golden medallion
that frank wilcheck left on my couch
earlier this week and that was
that the nobel prize had to be given to
those who had these
great inventions or discoveries in
physics
that caused the greatest benefit to
humanity in other words
the will was not just about money and
giving away attention
it was to advocate for the improvement
of the human condition
so it was an ethical will in addition to
being a material will
and it kind of encapsulated his wisdom
and his hopes for the future he had no
children
he was not married so this is really his
his ideological
uh um air i want to ask you john uh for
both your biological
progeny and your ideological progeny
which i count myself as one
influenced by you what ethical or piece
of wisdom
do you want to leave for the future uh
so that people can benefit
perhaps in the way they live their life
maybe not related to physics at all
but in terms of the wisdom that you've
developed during your time
on this spinning blue marble that we
call home
well that's uh that's a big question
i guess it would just be keep a sense of
humor
don't take yourself too seriously it's
okay to be self-confident
and arrogant sometimes but recognize
your own
voice and limitations and uh you know
appreciate
that uh you know one's idiosyncrasies
can be kind of funny
it's okay to make fun of yourself um
and uh you know actually uh
you what you know you quote you
mentioned one of my one of my favorite
uh
fineman quotes too which has related
wisdom
you're the easiest person to fool try to
be honest
um it's hard because uh
you know we do have biases and
but we have to uh do our best to uh
to make judgments uh that are sound even
about ourselves yeah
very very very uh sage advice okay the
next question
also goes into the future and that is
related to the movie 2001 a space
odyssey based on the arthur c
clarke book i don't know if you've ever
seen the movie but it opens i saw it
when it
first came out it was i was 16 i think
it wasn't in 1969
and my brother and i was in limited
engagement
in downtown chicago we were living in
the suburbs we took the train in because
we were so excited to see it
and uh you know we spent uh countless
hours afterwards trying to figure out
what it was about yeah it was a it was
an amazing cinematic
experience it was yeah kubrick is just
it's the highlight of
basically pinnacle of science fiction
movies in my opinion but that movie
opens
with these hominid-like creatures on the
plains of africa
presumably you know millions of years
ago thousands and hundreds of thousands
of years ago and they come upon this
monolith
this this mysterious object on the
savannah
and they hit it with a bone and they do
all sorts of crazy stuff to it and
then uh and then later astronauts
encounter the same
menacing you know monolith on the moon
in space etc and it's clearly meant to
be some sort of
time capsule for what purpose we don't
really know
i asked avi loeb last week what he would
put on it and he thinks we've been
visited by one of these monoliths but
you stay tuned two weeks from now i'll
have avilobe on my podcast for the
release of his new book called
extraterrestrial that's just a plug so
make sure you subscribe
but um i want to ask you if you had a
monolith
uh and it sort of reminded me of richard
feynman his again
making an appearance on the show he said
that if
in some cataclysm all scientific
knowledge were to be destroyed and only
one
sentence passed on to the next
generation of creatures
what statement would contain the most
information in the fewest words i won't
say
i'm sure you know what he said but i
want to ask you scientific or otherwise
i don't care
what you put on it could be a a quote it
could be your tattoo
it could be the tattoo you have on your
on your backside no just kidding you
don't have one of those
but uh but john what would you put on a
billion-year
lasting enduring time capsule uh wisdom
knowledge scientific or otherwise
right well simon said everything's made
of atoms
and of course that's a very good answer
and he
meant that you can understand a lot of
things just starting from that principle
i guess maybe i would um
i would be trying to convey not
necessarily the content of science but
how to do science the method of science
and um
well actually farming said something
good about that too right
in the character of physical law he said
uh
when it when you're trying to guess or
understand
the laws of nature it doesn't matter how
smart you are
you know it it doesn't matter
how important you are um if it disagrees
with experiment it's wrong
and so i think the the idea that we have
to look at the world
with objectivity we have to evaluate the
evidence
and if we have pet ideas
that we favor we have to uh
you know be willing to uh to test them
and if they fail we move on and in the
case of
a situation where we can't get
experimental evidence say for the
singularity at the core of a black hole
or the
origin of the universe in this in a
singularity event
um you know i i actually revealed you
know which i didn't know
but but you know stephen hawking's brief
history of time was really an advocacy
of this hard old hawking
you know no boundary condition and and
he used that for a particular purpose
in his case i'll talk about it on my
podcast with leonard melodna which comes
out this coming tuesday but
but nevertheless you know it's kind of
an advocacy against a supernatural
creator's necessity because one of the
jobs of a supernatural creator would be
to create the universe
and if the universe can emerge from
nothing essentially and this no boundary
or enough time itself can emerge from
nothing maybe
such an entity is not necessary but
nevertheless getting back to feynman if
it agrees if it disagrees with the
experiment it's wrong
what if you can't do the experiment what
do you do
keep trying keep thinking about it you i
mean
unless you have some entirely convincing
argument that it's impossible
to test the idea um keep trying
great okay john last question now we're
going to go backwards in time
and we're going to use the famous three
laws of arthur c clarke
the opening one of which opens the
podcast and that is any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic i love
that quote i love his second law of
arthur c
clarke is for every expert there is an
equal and opposite expert
and i think feynman said science is the
belief in the ignorance of experts
something like that
uh but the third law is the name of this
podcast
and it involves basically the following
sentence the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
so that's where i got the name of the
podcast so i want to ask you joan
what aspect of life seemed impossible to
a 20 year old 30 year old john preschool
but because of your courage because of
your integrity because of your
strength of character whatever you made
it possible what advice would you give
to the young john preschool to venture
beyond his comfort zone into the
impossible
well that there are several questions
there all rolled up into one it seems
um well this this doesn't directly
answer your question about advice to the
young john fresco but you know we did
encounter
in the early days of quantum computing
and to some degree even today
the uh objection or the viewpoint
that scaling up quantum computing is
impossible
and the basis for that well
different people might have different
reasons for raising that objection but
i remember in the mid 90s very very good
physicists
like um like bill unrwa he'd be a good
guest on your show yes
i'd love to have him on yeah i talked to
lenny about that yeah
and uh and also ralph landauer
and uh sergio roche and others argued
you know we'll never be able to get a
quantum computer to work and it's
because of decoherence well that
in particular foreign that was the
reason
uh we and hiroshi knew very well because
he'd worked very hard for a long time to
study coherence in the lab
it's just too pervasive it's too
unavoidable and it's impossible to get
around it
but you know we developed this idea of
quantum era correction which i think
in its long-term implications is as
important as the idea that
there are quantum algorithms that can
greatly outperform
classical ones and and so now um
most people who think seriously about it
believe we will
have large-scale quantum computers and
we'll protect them against decoherence
using this idea
of quantum error correction so that and
that was interesting to see that
unfold as far as advice i might give to
myself
um i'm sure i wouldn't have paid
attention to my own advice by the way
but
i probably when i was uh you know a
young theorist maybe
starting graduate school um
you know there were certain things i was
interested in and many things that i
thought
just aren't that interesting and and one
thing that might have been good advice
for me
at the time was pay more attention to
experiments
and i don't just mean the results of
them but experimental
techniques you know what people actually
do in the lab
to make stuff work i didn't learn much
about that
in my phd education and i think
if i had you know i would
have a better understanding even today
of
the practice of doing really hard
experiments which of course is very
relevant to trying to develop quantum
computers
absolutely and that brings out my last
imprecation or or for the future that
people should not be so siloed i always
say to my students who are
experimentalists that they don't need to
be
theorists they don't like to come up
with new theories and so forth but they
need to understand the theory
otherwise they're just kind of
mindlessly applying the you know
principles of electronics and plumbing
and so forth
and they're really not fulfilling their
potentiality to become you know
merchants of truth and
understand the essence of what they're
doing rather than just doing it to get a
phd etc i'd love to talk to you because
you are such an inspiring teacher
and mind and so forth love to talk to
you someday about
pedagogy and especially as i said when
your book comes out but maybe even
before that
because i think i've learned so much
from you you didn't
maybe ever hear it before now but but um
you're one of my
you know mentors in a remote sense i
look up to you i use you as sort of a
you know as a filter you won't like that
but you're kind of might if
it's interesting to preschool it's got
to be interesting enough for keating
so i want to thank you john for going
into the impossible with me
uh and i hope you stay well i hope we
see each other barry bearish
is offering to interview me for my
podcast he has some questions to ask me
so i might come up to pasadena
i'd love to see you and uh and just get
a socially distanced
you know fist bump from you i don't know
john stay well thank you for going into
the impossible
uh everybody um thank you i hope you
enjoyed this as much as i did thank you
for all your donations
you can still give to the foothill unity
center
it's a phenomenal organization and we
raised
about a hundred dollars maybe a little
bit more tally it up afterwards from
around the world i mean
you'll tell them john that they got
money from australia and from the uk
as well as from san diego john thank you
so much
this has been fun brian i'd be happy to
do it again sometime thank you so much
bye everybody stay tuned for more
episodes of into the impossible leonard
malodno avi loeb
we have deepak chopra in a solo episode
and uh hopefully we'll get uh people
like gerard tahuft and uh
and and others back on the show that
would be uh such a treat john thank you
so much stay
well